مرحبا على الجميع
في طفله عمرها ست سنين هل الطفله كانت
ماشيه بالشارع شافت شيء غريب شافت بنت
وامها شفايفهم ويتواصلوا بطريقه حركه
الشفايف الطفله كتير استغربت
استغربت راحت
على البيت سالت امها في اشخاص عم يحبوا
شفايفهم بدون ما يحركوا ايديهم كيف هدول
الاشخاص عم يتواصلون الضحكه وقالت نحن
عباره عن مجتمعين مجتمع للصم ومجتمعين
الطفله كانت بتعرف هاي المعلومه لاول مره
طبعا هاي القصه انا رشا خازن حاحكي لكم
قصه بشكل كامل طبعا في عنا مجتمعين مجتمع
للصوم مجتمعنا وهنتعرف عليهم بدايه انا من
المجتمع الصوم
عيلتي كلها من الاشخاص نستخدم حركات
الايدين بالتواصل رفقاتنا جيراننا كلياتهم
هذا المجتمع بدايه الدخول العالم السامعي
كنت صف اول فتت لمدرسه كلها اشخاص سامعين
هدول الاشخاص انا كنت لحالي صماء بيناتهم
ما كنت اقدر اتواصل معهم كونه طريقه
التواصل بتختلف بتذكر مره المعلمه كتبت
كلمه امتحان عن لوح
انا هفصل الكلمه بهذا الشكل فحسيت انه
ما فهمته ثاني يوم بروح على المدرسه بشوف
الطلاب عاملين هاي الحركه
فما عرفت شو تفسير هذا الموضوع لحتى اخر
الشيء عرفت هاي كلمه امتحان من بعدين
انتقلت
لمدرسه خاصه بس يمكن في كتير مبسوطه ضد
المدرسه الصم عم اتواصل بشكل واضح معاهم
عم يفهموا عليه عم بفهموا عليهم كمان
الموضوع جدا
كمان فيه
قرايبينا جيراننا رفقاتنا رفقات رفقاتنا
اعدادنا كبيره نحنا جزء من 72 مليون شخص
حول العالم اكثر من 300 لغه
اكثر من 300 لغه اشاره طبعا نحن بتجمع
نا مناطق مدارس بس بقي عندي فضول الطفله
عندي شغف لحتى افوت لعالم السامعين بس
خلصت البكالوريا الطلب
لدوله تدريبيه مع الاشخاص السامعين وطبعا
تتاسفوا مني لانه ما عندهم مترجم لغه
الاشاره وبالتالي استصعب التواصل معاي
كنيسه فكرت في حل جبت فريق تطوعي بلشنا
نشتغل على فكره اللي هي المساواه ودعم
والتمكين والدمج ضمن المجتمع يصيرون
المجتمعين يساعدوا بعض مجتمع السامعي
بطريقه متساويه جهزت الفريق
[موسيقى]
الجسم بتناسق منسجم
وكل حركه هي اشاره توصيه كلمه شام ليش هيك
كلمه شام لانه من زمان الشباب
كانوا يمسكوا على شواربهم فهيك كلمه شام
مثلا مدينه حلب هي بهذا الشكل لانه حبيت
حلب هي الظاهره تميزت اهالي حلب فحلب بهذا
الشكل الرقه هيك بهذا الشكل لانه الاشخاص
هنن بيرقصوا بهذا الفلور فالرقم هذا الشكل
في عنا درعا درعا لمدرج بصره فدرعه
فايشاره درعا هيك سويدا
اهالي السويداء فهيك اشاره السويدا
هاي لغه الاشاره الحركات التوصيه كل كلمه
طبعا نحن نستخدم اشاره عربيه سوريه
واشارات عالميه مثلا بكلمه هي اشاره
عالميه تعتبر بس نحن هون عنا الخبراء
الصوم هن مانهم موافقين دائما انه يدخلوا
اشارات اجنبيه
كونه ممكن الشباب ينسوا اصاله الاشاره
العربيه ويتجهوا للاشارات الاجنبيه نحن
بنحافظ على اشارتنا العربي السوريه كونه
هي اشاره اصيله وطبعا بسوريا سوريا كان
لها دور كثير كبير كانت هي مقر الاتحاد
العربي للصمو منها تم انشاء القاموس
الاشاري العربي اللي هو كان مقر سوريا في
سوريا
وطبعا نحن كفريق
كمجتمع مجتمع الصمت نحن الاخبار بين بعض
بتنتشر بشكل سريع حاخبركم كيف نحن فورا اي
معلومه بتوصلنا عن طريق البث المباشر عن
طريق مكالمات الفيديو بتنتشر ما بين كل
عالم نصهم فبتزيد التوعيه ضمن هذا المجتمع
الموجود
الفريق اللي عم بشتغل فيه هو كثير عم
يحاول ينشر التوعيه من المجتمع ويحاول انه
طبعا هون ضمن
دمج الشباب ضمن المجتمع هدفه تنميه
المجتمعات ما بعد الازمه نحن اليوم هون
حنحكي عن هذا الموضوع وطبعا اشاره تنكس
القصه هي هيك بهذا الشكل
هاي اشاره المجتمع وهاي التنميه وبعد
الازمه تمام هيدا مره ثانيه
المجتمع مع بعض الازمات شكرا لالكم
[تصفيق]